Олексій Гончаренко ми безумовно будемо
підтримувати цей законопроект бо треба
людям допомогти отримати гроші
відбудувати житло бо стільки горя в
державі тільки знаєте а Який сенс В
цьому Ну от ми проголосуємо черговий
закон а хто його буде виконувати а хто
реально дасть ці гроші ми з вами вже
прийняли закон рівно півроку тому про
повернення тридцятки всім
військовослужбовцям всім і що
заблокований спікером президен не
підписаний в силу не вступив в нас гроші
ми виплачуємо на дитину 860 грн на
місяць в нас викинуті просто викинуті
хворі та поранені військовослужбовці
поза штат отримують 500 600 700 грн на
місяць всім байдуже залізничники медики
ніхто нічого не отримує все баййдеже на
них грошей нема А на що гроші є на
барабани на серіали на на Асфальт щоб
його
вкрасти от я говорю їм все байдуже от
слухам байдуже ну в них своє життя вони
в Дубаях замовляють собі чи в Тайланді
готелі вони собі константу обговорюють і
откат спробуємо їх може розбудить Окей я
вас спробую хоч трішки розбудити бо вони
дуже слухали А ви знаєте на що ще
знайшов наш Уряд гроші Кабінет Міністрів
України на День вчителя призначив
довічну стипендію зеленському Олександру
семеновичу батьку президента України
Володимира Олександровича Зеленського
це сама злиденна людина в Україні на
військових нема на дітей нема на
Володимира Олександровича і його родину
є кінець епохи бідності настав Оце воно
що надалі Президентський президент сам
собі героя України дасть ганьба ви
зупинитесь вам не соромно ні їм не
соромно